iMacs by being so large and you having  this illusion that you're sitting almost  inside the screen you feel part of the  movie rather than just an observer  that's why IMAX is kind of wonderful  the IMAX experience is really about full  world immersion the idea of really  transporting some someone to someplace  that they've never been before or  couldn't go in their lives and certainly  Ridley delivered any time you just sort  of look up at the screen you feel like  you are there and then nobody does that  like IMAX has that if you go down there  you're going to die are junaid  experience prometheus  IMAX 3d  big things have small beginnings  atheists in theaters June a go to IMAX  calm for show times and listings